hallo leute ich wieder eure pippi
langstrumpf von willkommen zu diesem
kindheitserinnerung flashback ich hoffe
ihr habt keinen hunger denn es wird viel
gegessen nachdem ich die drk werbung aus
den 50er jahren gefunden habe hat sich
der algorithmus auf youtube gedacht ja
gut die möchte werbung sehen und seit
dem krieg ständig irgendwelche werbung
von früher vorgeschlagen wie zum
beispiel auch diese super rtl werbung
[Applaus]
diese werbung ist aus 2005 da war ich
[Musik]
zwölf jahre alt klar als ich zwölf jahre
alt war und diese werbung gesehen habe
wollte ich natürlich alles kaufen konnte
ich zu dem zeitpunkt nicht aber dafür
heute und das werden wir heute alles mal
so durchgehend fangen wir an soll vom 7
dass sie die schokolade zum trinken
der aus frischer milch kommt es euch
auch sofort dass man die sachen die man
als kind gesehen hat dass die einfach
für immer im kopf gespeichert sind ich
glaube mit 80 werde ich noch diesen emmi
caffe latte song singen können wie
schokolade ist unser erstes produkt ich
hab die leben durch gesucht und ich
konnte tatsächlich schokolade nicht mehr
finden
ich habe aber von emmi noch die café
latte gefunden café latte mit einem
hauch von schokolade das ist jetzt das
aus dem am nächsten kommt ungefähr 20
gramm zucker sentiert drin wie viel
zucker darf ein mensch am tag trinken
konsumieren whu 50 gramm zucker pro tag
das heißt ein becher an du hast schon
fast durch zu sein ist aber wissen wie
schmeckt ja das ist natürlich legal aber
auch extrem süß ist schon echt zu süß
ich mache natürlich auch gerne mal was
süßes trinken aber dann schmeckt auf
jeden fall den kaffee man schmeckt die
schokolade für mich würde es durchfallen
ich finde diese dinge also auch nicht
nur wegen dem plastik sondern auch
wenigen geschmack das ist mir einfach ja
viel zu süß schokolade wir machen wir
weiter mit dem nächsten produkt
[Musik]
ich hab versucht kann du im laden zu
finden konnte man nicht also ich glaube
im kaufland online shop konnte man das
bestellen und auf amazon obviously aber
ich wollte jetzt auch nicht dafür machen
ich finde es ja eigentlich ganz gut wenn
man den kindern beibringt sich feucht
abzuwischen und nicht mit trockenem
toilettenpapier so wie wir das heute
machen habe ich mit von gemisches hat
das eigentlich ganz gut gesagt das ist
als ob man kaka meldungen hat und es
trocken einfach wegwischen feuchttücher
sind allerdings jetzt auch nicht die
beste lösung ich glaube im endeffekt
muss man sich wirklich angewöhnen mit so
happy end nas sich den hintern sauber zu
machen so weitergehen
monti com kennst du schon den monte
drink
jetzt kann ich überall mit hin kommen in
die schule beim sport sogar ins
schwimmbad von der werbung her kommt es
jetzt gerade mir so vor als ob es sich
um ein sportliches isotonisches getränk
haid behandelt ich hatte ihn so schön
vorbereitet den satz der neue top monte
drink der einzige trinkt für kinder mit
in die frische milch schokolade und im
westen der haselnuss
es handelt sich hier also um ein getränk
für kinder mit viel frischer milch dem
besten der schokolade viel schokolade
und den besten der haselnuss die packung
die wir gefunden haben hat sogar
menschen drauf der sport treibt der hat
zehn gramm zucker auf 100 milliliter
hier sind wieder 20 gramm zucker drin
guckt euch das getränk anders ist das
wenn sich klein
ich meine sie erwähnen die wichtigsten
zutaten aber eine hat haben sie
vergessen dass sportliche isotonische
getränk monte nehme ich mit zum sport
zum schwimmbad als ob das hier wirklich
irgendwie nach affäre schiffsleute
erstes was reingeht ist süß schmeckt ihm
protein shake das muss an dem eiweiss
liegen was sie da irgendwie zugefügt
haben
ich war wird dieses produkt so was von
den zoff monte ist halt bisher also ein
pudding und das ist halt ein pudding zum
trinken aber ich verstehe diese ganze
sportliche kampagne drumherum ich
probiert den selber oder leisten dass
das bleiben lassen es lieber bleiben
lassen bleiben machen wir mal weiter in
der stadt aufgewachsen
wach endlich auf du verluste haben in
der wildnis gestrandet
die ermordet und ihre leber gefressen
reingefallen
von den machern von das ist 16 jahre
das ist 16 jahre her
16 jahre existenzkrise
heute hört mir zu leben genießen es ist
schneller vorbei als man glauben
madagaskar also ich könnte mir jetzt den
film madagascar anschauen
[Applaus]
wir schauen uns mal eine filmkritik zu
marias kanada in der review gelesen es
ist nicht rock oder findet nemo aber es
ist wert die acht dollar 25 würde ich so
unterschreiben
madagaskar schaut euch auf jeden fall
diesen film an ich bin schockiert dass
der schon 2016 jahre 16 jahre leute was
soll ich noch sagen
gehen wir mal zur nächsten werbung wir
haben ja noch ein paar
[Musik]
richtig
zumal das übt schon mal das saugen
monate davor sich seit das ganze pulver
gel börse aus dem kühlregal ich habe nur
ein problem mit diesem produkt man kann
es nicht mehr finden und nicht nur das
ist das produkt nicht mehr im kühlregal
gibt es ist vom internet verschollen aus
an dieser werbung und in einem artikel
den ich gefunden habe wird es erwähnt
und weil es das nicht gibt machen wir es
selber dieses videos nicht gesponsorten
company ltd
ich habe vergessen dass man auch haus ja
eigentlich in ein getränk macht und
dadurch seine brause kreiert sagt mir
bitte legt sich die einzige wenn sie das
als kind immer so gegessen hat und wie
von zauberhand erscheint jetzt wie ihr
heu brause gilbert 11 mit milram und so
ich war dämlich und haben wir jetzt mal
sich nach der zubereitung von dem bronze
clippers mal warten muss bis das fest
wird
ich meine den clip vom probieren werdet
ihr jetzt sehen wir haben einen kleinen
zeitsprung aber das clever ist jetzt
fertig und jetzt üben wir schon mal das
saugen vielleicht kriege ich sehr hin
eins davon weg zu sagen ich weiß nicht
warum es in zwei ich wollte am mail ich
dachte was machen unterschiede gemacht
technisch es ist halt jetzt so ein
wackelpudding sieht irgendwie falsch aus
mein gott ich habe damals diesen gräbern
nicht probiert aber wenn ich den
probiert hätte ich schwöre euch der
hätte so geschmeckt kann mir schon
vorstellen warum es nicht so erfolgreich
waren sie die produktion eingestellt
haben geschmacklich finde ich wirklich
gut also es ist so dieser ahoi brause
zitronengeschmack der kickt voll gut
rein und es schmeckt wirklich sehr
lecker aber wenn sie was sie damals mit
der konsistenz gemacht haben ja war mega
die gute idee wenn ihr zu hause
nachmachen wollte ich habe das
götterspeise pulver in wasser aufgelöst
dann die ahoi brausepulver tütchen
dazugepackt zwei oder drei stück so wie
ihr es wollt und dann aufgekocht und
machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt
lisa und fruchtig frisch aus der
tiefgarage und als etablierte nach maß
prickel der ahoi brause eiszeit das ist
nicht ganz das originalprodukt von
damals aber ich denke mal was soll sich
großartig verändert haben und es gibt
sogar ein zweites ich habe jetzt mal
beide mitgenommen um sie einfach zu
probieren und man weiß nie was man
bekommt
das ist der überraschungs mix
weltmeister und ich glaube himbeere
oh mein gott das schmeckt nach kindheit
bastelecke wie die brausetabletten von
der apotheke die man als kind bekommen
hat damit man ein bisschen magnesium
herauszufischen
dieses eis muss sich timo wahrscheinlich
gleich abgeben weil milch molke zeugnis
aber probieren kann ich trotzdem
also das ist der browser becher das ist
einfach ein kleiner mit flori gepresst
auch im haus also mit milch die
kombination ist aber jetzt ganz komisch
und himbeer wir das meer aber jetzt
hinter dem safe gefeiert sagt deniz oder
front 13 gramm sogar kein wunder dass
ist gut schmeckt unsere nächste werbung
kalt
legt alle im internet er erlebt tolle
abenteuer im internet
dieser werbespruch ist führt einkauf das
ist mir so im kopf geblieben das design
hat sich über die jahre nur ein bisschen
verändert aber der geschmack ist der
gleiche zitrone orange und kirche
gekauft
oh ich hab jetzt so lange nicht mehr
gekauft früher war das voll das denkt
pure zu gerne 50 gramm zucker das ist
halt das ist ein zuckerzusatz sogar wer
erinnert sich noch an diese dinger ich
wette dass die werbung bei mir super
funktioniert hat weil wenn ich das sehe
kriege ich richtig warme kindheits
gefühle
es hat früher anders geschmeckt ist der
besondere geschmack von fritz ist glaube
ich einfach diese verpackung ich habe
das gefühl man schmeckt die verpackung
und ist früher die verpackung nicht auch
immer so ein bisschen kleben geblieben
wenn ich mir schon 50 gramm pro 100
gramm zucker reife würde ich nicht
zufrieden
schreibt mir gerne eure erinnerung zu
frites wir machen weiter mich lässt
gerade diese erinnerung nicht los dass
man diese papierfetzen noch auf diesem
schritt hatte das neue telefon ist die
streichen muss nur als prima winter
wussten verwandeln sie ihr frühstück
snakes zu lecker dazu sei nicht neu
ja da habe ich mich müssen schlecht
gefühlt an sorry die show keller von
nestlé
[Musik]
ich dachte auch das hotel herum ist
alles dicht wie möglich durch die
extreme leckeres nur mit knieschmerzen
das ist neu das ist so keller also denn
so lecker dass sie fast nicht wahr sind
weiß ich nicht ich habe sie tatsächlich
noch nie probiert damals hat meine
eltern nicht genug geld um sich die
teuren marken zu leisten deswegen ja gab
es bei uns immer die aldi
beziehungsweise wieder version heute
heißen sie kopie christ aber hier steht
noch show keller drauf und es sind post
mit nutella drauf 24 gramm zucker
früher habe ich wirklich gedacht das ist
so das was man zum frühstück ist ich
habe jeden morgen an welche zehn
minister also die von aldi gegessen
irgendwas in dieser form aber man hat
sich ja schon morgens die zucker keule
gegeben dann ist man zur schule gefahren
habe diesen zucker high und kein wunder
dass man schon nach einer stunde da saß
und wieder komplett fertig war die sehen
aus wie kleine leute gebt euch diesen
kleinen tost man schmeckt tatsächlich
das vollkorn ist hat schon so ne
gesunden ich muss sie mit milch
probieren also ich weiß nicht wie sie es
machen aber obwohl da so viel zucker
drin ist schmeckt auch nicht sowieso
schon lecker in die konsistenz mega
schmecken mir so einem teller tost als
komplex es ist quasi der teufel als
frühstücks flakes aber schmeckt halt
machen wir weiter ich bin der waschen
geist vom sex und macht sich fragen die
du willst und dann immer wieder neu
der magischen unterwasserwelt ist jetzt
auch die schöne mädchen und dann auch
das piratenschiff mit dem raucher und
dem handspiel mit josi spiel mit josi
mein gott leute der magic cent gehört
wirklich zu den top drei sachen die
jetzt kind haben wollte aber nie
bekommen habt dann habe ich diese
werbung gesehen und mich dazu
entschlossen die sachen nach zu kaufen
dann hab ich gesehen dass das das nicht
mehr gibt und dann bin ich auf ebay
gegangen und habe jemanden gefunden der
den magic sind so wie man ihn in der
werbung sieht verkauft der magix mit
dieser komische verpackung wie uns die
werbung schon verraten hat wird dieser
sand nie so wirklich nass also man kann
ihn ins wasser machen und tolle gebilde
machen und dann einfach wieder raus
holen dann ist er trocken magix
ich habe auf diesem kanal schon mal
magix 10 probiert aber es war kein etic
senna dass dieser mit dem man bauen kann
und dass ich einfach so ein bisschen
bewegt und kannst crazy ist aber der das
ist sie also ich hab auf ebay glaube ich
350 pro packung oder vier euro pro
packung bezahlt denn bis xl mit dem
magic schaufel und nachhaltig schaufel
schon einmal meinen wasserbecken
hey leute ich leb wirklich um einen
zwölfjährigen traum wir bauen jetzt
tolle gebildet können wir damit bauen
türme brücken alles weitere die die
schwimmt oben drauf das stimmt nur
obendrauf habe sich das bei mir so
stream schoss das ist gar nicht cool
das ist es zum nummer eins war jetzt
eine coole brücke ja ja es ist wirklich
das coolste was ich jemals gesehen habe
so jetzt kommt der grosse test es waren
wasser und jetzt hole ich es raus ihr
wisst was jetzt passiert dann kann das
ja gar nicht so richtig stapeln
ich habe auf der oberfläche mehr magix
ändert aber anders für mona sich das nie
bekommen habe als kind heiliges zu tode
gefeiert was ist es das diesen sand so
trocken hält
hier ist eine bewusst gemacht noch wir
kommen zu meinem kanal spiel mit mir
kinderspielzeug und dann nehme ich jetzt
den tollen magic cent und jetzt habe ich
was an meinem magic cent das tor hätte
ein problem da das ja ich nehme doch
viel mehr wasser als alles andere dass
er jetzt wasser in der schaufel wie soll
das denn jetzt zurück kippen
das ist am 5 die geiseln wieder
zurückholen wenn das alles voller wasser
ist also dass bisher die größte sauerei
kein wunder dass meine eltern mir das
nicht kaufen wollten
so und jetzt kann das jetzt kommt denkst
ich will doch das wasser daraus haben
dass so viel wasser drin und ich bin im
kreis gefahren ich muss jetzt wieder
damit spielen na ja das gefühl dass ich
das zeug ein atme aber ist nicht giftig
jedoch der packung recht wie soll man
das zurück schütten ich verstehe es
nicht ist es voll mit wasser ich kann
man magic sind deswegen nicht mehr
kaufen
das ist nicht wissenschaft dass hier
wieder raus zu bringen als ob das ein
fünfjähriges kind hinkriegt
gebrauchsanleitung um das wasser
vollkommen vom sand ab zu gießen läge
ein papiertuch in dein hase oder tee sie
und gießt das wasser aus dem behälter
dadurch ab jetzt kannst du den trockenen
sand zurück in die flasche bringen hat
wäre ich ein kind würde das magic cent
ding zehn von zehn punkte bekommen ganz
klar als erwachsener die das danach
wieder sauber machen muss ist
durchgefallen
das ist so eine sauerei spiel mit susie
machen wir mit dem nächsten produkt
weiter
kopien sind wieder die motive zum
sammeln und spielen
micky maus die dienst dort neu und weil
er etwas produkt was wir testen ist das
micky maus magazin
ich habe leider das micky maus comics
nur noch gefunden ich weiß nicht ob es
das micky maus magazin noch geld kostet
399 dies ist gut wer noch nie ein comic
gelesen hat sollte es unbedingt mal tun
es hat einen ganz eigenen charme ich
meine man kann ja auch anders lesen oder
halt lustige taschenbuch und tokio
ich habe noch nie so einen comic gekauft
jetzt haben wir eine schöne klo lektüre
für 399 zwölf geschichten was will man
mehr und wenn ihr das jetzt mal bei mir
auf toilette seid könnt ihr euch die
geschichten durch lesen jetzt ist aber
wirklich schluss mit lustig das einzige
was wir jetzt noch probieren sollten ist
der fleck und lag 0 der turbo flick und
legt los
es gibt leider nicht mehr den taube
flick und legten es gibt nur noch den
hier
ich fand den tango schon cool ich glaube
es hat sich aber nicht viel verändert
mein ums becken ging es gar nicht so
donnert das ist der original flick und
liegt hier seht ihr hier stets darauf
flick und blick der geschmacks
katastrophe ja der torwart und mit glory
ein spaß für die ganze familie
ich vermisse die guten alten zeiten und
ich hoffe natürlich euch hat das video
gefallen welche produkte waren eure
kindheit favorite schreibt gerne in die
kommentare gibt dem video daumen nach
oben wenn ihr mich unterstützen wollte
und wenn euch das video gefallen hat und
abonniert hier diese kanäle lauf
schwarzmeer falls sie auf dem er steht
gaming channel ab und zu kommt da auch
mal was hier könnt ihr mich abonnieren
und da gibt's neues video alles klar
bis dann